FOOT OF WALL CONSTRUCTED DURING
MY ADMINISTRATION.
>> WHY IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING A BORDER
WALL IN ARIZONA?
>> SO, UM, WE ARE NOT -- WE'RE
NOT FINISHING THE WALL.
WE ARE CLEANING UP THE MESS THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION LEFT BEHIND
IN THEIR FAILED ATTEMPT TO BUILD
A WALL.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TRIED
TO DEFEND AUTHORIZING FUNDING TO
CLOSE MULTIPLE BORDER WALL GAPS
IN THE YUMA, ARIZONA SECTOR.
THE PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN TRAIL
PROMISE NOT TO BUILD ANOTHER
FOOT.
LET'S START WITH THE TEAM.
KEVIN WALLING, AND PROJECT 21
CO-CHAIR HORACE COOPER.
GENTLEMEN, GREAT TO HAVE YOU
BACK WITH US TONIGHT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> HEY, SHANNON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE CHIEF
TWEETED TODAY.
HE SAYS, WE'RE FUNDED TO CLOSE
FOUR BORDER GAPS IN YUMA SOCCER,
DETERRING MIGRANTS FROM CROSSING
IN THIS DANGEROUS AREA,
ACCOUNTING FOR 45,761
APPREHENSIONS AND 45 WATER
RESCUES AND, HORACE, A GUEST WE
HAD ON THIS WEEK SAID THERE HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF DEATHS.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS TREK THAT
PEOPLE GO ON, COMING HERE.
SO, THE WALL CLOSING, WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT, THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS NOW'S THE
TIME FOR THAT.
>> SEE, THIS ADMINISTRATION
INSTEAD OF JUST AGREEING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING, THE WALL IS A GOOD
IDEA, AND IT SAVES LIVES.
BUT, INSTEAD, WE HAVE TO
REDEFINE.
WE'RE NOT REBUILDING THE WALL;
WE'RE SAVING LIVES.
INFLATION IS JUST TENTATIVE,
IT'S GONNA PASS, IT'S
TRANSITORY, EXCEPT IT'S NOW AT A
40-YEAR HIGH.
IT'S NOT A RECESSION.
THAT'S NOT THE TECHNICAL TERM
FOR WHAT'S GOING ON WHEN, IN
FACT, AMERICANS ARE SAYING AT
LEVELS WE'VE NOT HEARD SINCE THE
JIMMY CARTER ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S A RECESSION, IT'S TERRIBLE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION SHOULD STOP
PLAYING THE WORD GAMES.
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE IT TO KEVIN, OUR
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST HERE.
UM, CONGRESSMAN ANDREW CLYDE,
HE'S A REPUBLICAN FROM GEORGIA
TWEETS THIS:  AFTER HISPANIC
SUPPORT FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
CRATERS TO 27% APPROVAL, HE
WANTS TO COMPLETE THE WALL.
>> SO MANY LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST,
INCLUDING THE LIFE OF A
5-YEAR-OLD GIRL WHO JUST DROWNED
LAST MONTH AT THAT BORDER
CROSSING.
SO, THERE'S AN APPROPRIATION OF
THAT MONEY TO FILL IN THOSE GAPS
AROUND YUMA, ARIZONA.
WE GOT TO TAKE THE POLITICS OUT
OF THIS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY ABOUT SAVING
LIVES OF THESE MIGRANT SO
DESPERATE TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY, INCLUDING THAT LITTLE
GIRL WHO GOT SEPARATED FROM HER
MOM.
I WANT TO PUT THE PUBLICS ASIDE,
IF WE CAN, AND DO THE RIGHT
THING.
WHICH IS, TO HORACE'S POINT,
BUILDING THE WALL AND INCREASE
FUNDING FOR PAROLE OFFICERS AND
BORDER ENHANCEMENTS.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
DIFFERENT FROM MANY WHO SAID
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE AT THE BORDER.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ANOTHER
ISSUE, DEALING WITH CHINA.
DAVID, YOU'RE OUR EXPERT HERE ON
FOREIGN POLICY ON THIS PANEL, SO
LET'S TALK THROUGH THIS.
NANCY PELOSI IS HEADING OUT ON
AN ASIA TRIP AND THREATS THAT
POSSIBLY HER PLANE COULD BE SHOT
OUT OF THE SKY, OR SHOULD BE BY
SOME CRACKPOT IN CHINA IF SHE
SHOULD DARE TO GO VISIT TAIWAN.
HERE'S FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO.
NANCY, I'LL GO WITH YOU.
I'M BANNED IN CHINA BUT NOT
FREEDOM-LOVING TAIWAN.
SEE YOU THERE.
THERE ARE THOSE ON THE RIGHT WHO
SAY SHE SHOULD GO.
THE HILL HAS THIS HEADLINE
TODAY.
HE SLAMS PELOSI VISIT.
SHE WILL ONLY MAKE IT WORSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HER
POTENTIAL VISIT?
>> THIS IS SUCH AN INTERESTING
STANDOFF.
YOU KNOW, THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE HAS THE RIGHT TO GO TO
VISIT TAIWAN IF SHE WANTS TO.
CONGRESS IS A COEQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT AND AS A LEADER IN
CONGRESS, IT'S IMPORTANT FOR HER
TO VISIT OUR ALLIES AND TAIWAN
IS A DEMOCRATIC ALLY.
CHINA HAS ACTUALLY MADE IT MORE
LIKELY SHE'S GOING TO GO.
IF SHE DOESN'T GO NOW, PEOPLE
WILL THINK SHE DIDN'T GO BECAUSE
CHINA INSTRUCTED HER NOT TO, AND
CHINA HAS NO RIGHT TO INSTRUCT
ANY U.S. OFFICIAL, WHETHER IT IS
A CONGRESSWOMAN OR SOMEONE IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NOT TO
GO AND VISIT TAIWAN.
IF WE BACK DOWN NOW, YOU KNOW,
WHAT WILL CHINA DO THE NEXT TIME
SOMEONE WANTS TO VISIT TAIWAN?
THEIR RESPONSE WILL BE EVEN
STRONGER AND MORE THREATENING.
I DO THINK CHINA MAY TAKE SOME
PROVOCATIVE ACTION.
I THINK IT'S VERY UNLIKELY THAT
CHINA WILL MAKE THE MISTAKE OF
ENDANGER THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE OR DOING ANYTHING TO
ENDANGER HER AIRLINE FLIGHT INTO
TAIWAN.
>> Shannon: DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ARE FLIPPING SIDES
AND FINDING ALLIANCES ABOUT
WHETHER SHE SHOULD GO OR NOT.
IT'S A WEIRD WASHINGTON THING
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
>> THERE ARE INTERESTING DUCHESS
OF SUSSEX --
WE GOT TO REMEMBER, SPEAKER
PELOSI HAS A LONG HISTORY WITH
TAIWAN AND THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
REGIME.
SHE WAS IN TIANANMEN SQUARE
PROTESTING FOR A HUMAN RIGHTS
BRING THE FIGHT TO CHINA.
SHE BELIEVES STRONGLY IN THIS
AND SEEING POTENTIALLY THIS
MIGHT BE HER LAST TERM AS
SPEAKER, I DON'T BELIEVE IT AS
THE DEMOCRAT ON YOUR PANEL, BUT
THIS WOULD BE A SERIOUS CAPSTONE
FOR HER BELIEVING STRONGLY SHE'S
GOT TO GO AND BE PRESENT IN
TAIWAN.
>> Shannon: YEAH, THE WHITE
HOUSE TAKING HEAT FOR NOT HAVING
A MORE CLEAR MESSAGE ON THIS
ISSUE.
BUT ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH DOMESTICALLY IS THE
ECONOMY.
HORACE YOU REFERENCED THIS IDEA
OF CHANGING WORDS AND
DEFINITIONS AND THAT KIND OF
THING.
POLITICO SAYS, WAIT, IS BIDEN A
BETTER PRESIDENT THAN PEOPLE
THOUGHT?
THEY SAY, FOLLOWING A PATTERN,
BIDEN IS LOOKING A LITTLE LIKE
THE STUDENT WHO'S FAILING HIS
CLASS FOR MOST OF THE SEMESTER
AND THEN PULLS AN ALL-NIGHTER
AND SLIPS THE PAPER UNDER THE
PROFESSOR'S DOOR AND THE PAPER
IS GOOD.
NO WAY HE'S GETTING AN A FOR THE
TERM OR NO FAIR GRADER WOULD
GIVE HIM AN F.
A SOLID B IS WITHIN REACH.
>> I USED TO TEACH
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
I KNOW OF THIS EXPERIENCE OR
ATTEMPT ON THE PART OF STUDENTS,
AND THEY DID NOT GET A B, THEY
DID NOT GET A C.
THEY MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN A D.
CLASS PARTICIPATION AND WHAT YOU
DO FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE TERM
MATTER.
THIS PRESIDENT, EVERY TIME HE
HAS TOUCHED A POLICY, WHETHER
IT'S ENERGY, WHETHER IT'S THE
ECONOMY, WHETHER IT'S
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS, HE HAS
MADE IT WORSE.
AND FOR HIM TO THINK THERE'S
SOME LITTLE CLEVER THING HE CAN
SORT OF CRAM IN AT THE LAST
MINUTE, LIKE THIS NEW DEAL HE'S
WORKED OUT WITH MANCHIN, I TELL
YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT AND YOU
GRADE IT, YOU'RE GONNA GIVE THAT
AN F.
NOTHING HAS IMPROVED.
>> Shannon: I'M GOING TO HAVE
NIGHTMARES TONIGHT, THE ONES I
ALWAYS HAVE ABOUT LAW SCHOOL
SHOWING UP AT THE WRONG PLACE
FOR MY EXAM AND EVERYTHING